people all over the US are feeling the
burn but the organization responsible
for getting democrats in office maybe
not so much that's a big problem for the
Bernie Sanders campaign because the
Democratic National Committee holds a
lot of power they help campaigns they
organize debates and they define the
party's position on a range of issues
but the DNC is also very old-school
they've been around since 1848
strengthening the two-party system that
makes it nearly impossible for a
third-party candidate to win elections
and may be hard for Bernie to Sanders
for most of his 35-year political career
has been an independent not a Democrat
and he's dissed both the two-party
system and the Democratic machine in the
past even calling the party
ideologically bankrupt for a group that
values loyalty that's a bit of a problem
to make matters worse the person calling
the shots at the DNC is debbie Wasserman
Schultz who back in 2008 co-chaired
Hillary Clinton's presidential campaign
and the DNC's finance chairman was
caught raising money for Clinton in June
many say that shows the DNC already has
a favorite but why would the DNC pick
sides folks in the Democratic
establishment see Clinton as the
candidate who's more likely to win the
general election but money was also a
factor few people can raise money like
Clinton in 2015 she raised way more than
Sanders she's also got a lot of wealthy
contacts and support from corporations
that's the kind of politics the DNC is
used to Sanders on the other hand relies
on small donations but he's getting a
lot of them in fact he reached 2 million
donations faster than Obama did in 2008
that's a sign that he has a lot of
popular support but some of his
progressive policies make corporations
nervous and the DNC isn't as comfortable
without setting these big corporate
donors so how else does Bernie field
burned by the DNC well in December a
sander staffer access confidential voter
information from the Clinton
pain on a database shared by Democrats
many think that what happened next was
an example of Clinton favoritism the DNC
cut off the Sanders campaign from its
own voter data even after the staffer
was fired by their action the leadership
of the Democratic National Committee is
now actively attempting to undermine our
campaign the DNC restored access only
after Sanders suit another way the DNC
is perhaps playing favorites they've
limited the number of debates but why
does this matter well if you're Clinton
it doesn't she's been in the public eye
for decades and she gets way more news
coverage in the Sanders that means
debates are crucial for candidates like
Sanders to get their names out there and
challenge Clinton on her policies but
the DNC has only scheduled six debates
most of them airing on weekends or when
other big events are on TV unless people
are watching and unlike in 2008 it says
it will punish any candidate who
participates in debates not approved by
the DNC so has the establishment decided
on Clinton before voters have even had a
say